هل تعتقد
أنه
سيتم السماح للفتيات الصغيرات بالمدارس الثانوية
بالذهاب إلى المدرسة هنا في
أفغانستان
كان الماء الساخن ، أود أن أقدم
بعض التوضيح ،
لا يوجد أحد يعارض
تعليم النساء
، ويسمح بالفعل للفتيات بالذهاب إلى
المدرسة
حتى  الصف السادس
وما فوق ذلك الصف
يستمر العمل على آلية
ربما تكون قد سمعت أن هذا لا
يعارض على مستوى القيادة
أو مجلس الوزراء
ولكن
تم تأجيل القضية حتى إشعار آخر
في الإعلان المقدم من
وزارة التعليم هناك  بعض
أوجه القصور في الإعداد التي
كانت
مستمرة في العمل على هذه القضايا من
خلال هذه المقابلة
والقناة الإخبارية ، وأنا أؤكد أنه
لا يوجد أحد يعارض التعليم
فقط
يمكن أن تخبرنا عندما تعتقد أن ذلك
سيحدث وأنا أعلم أنه كان هناك عدد كبير
لقاء في قندهار مع المرشد الأعلى
السيد أهن زاده
هل يمكن أن تخبرني ما إذا كان
قد تم اتخاذ أي قرارات خلال الأيام القليلة الماضية
ما أقوله
أنت ستسمع قريبًا أخبارًا جيدة جدًا حول هذا
الموضوع إن شاء الله
سنحدد الوقت
على الترتيب الذي تم
توفيره من قبل القيادة
الجارية على ذلك وستسمع
أخبارًا جيدة جدًا قريبًا.